hallo freunde herzlich willkommen beck
zu einer weiteren folge war u3 abgeht
rhyner st wir sind am arsch der welt das
heißt niemand wird uns denke ich nach
geräumt sein wollen wir wie ich mit
lange gegen eine höhle und wir zeigen
wie immer bei nacht bisschen scheint
wohl eher am tag aufnehmen
du bist nun verwundbar so laufen wir
jetzt erstmal suchen uns eine fette
höhle suchen dann diamanten oder fast
unser skelett das gleicht das skelett
und lass es töten kommt unser erster
kampf nein nein ich habe zombie gekillt
okay das skelett ist nach unten gefallen
aber ich möchte noch mal hingehen ich
möchte unter grüner situation geraten da
zwei herzen verloren
wir müssen definitiv brauchen wie reisen
das heißt lasst mal runter gehen dass
man irgendwie einfach höhlen suchen
kommt somit bis hinter mir ich würde
gern besuchen diamanten finden
geil sein das will jeder glaube ich
zuckerrohrs langen und müssen aber auch
aufpassen weil rechts in kryta hängt der
seite sicher kommt oder so weber bleibt
hirn oben ja bleibt auch noch mal habe
ich doch das ist hinter der grenze der
grenze hinter der krankheit
das ist hinter der grenze was auf dessen
zombie mit rüstung neben die eu kommt
mit weiter dahin sind definitiv lang
lang ist ein holz holen ich glaube wir
sind nicht die einzigen die noch nicht
so krass mit eisen ausgestattet sind
weil wir einfach keins finden
das ist nicht wahr auch ich dachte
hinten wüsten tempel ach du heilige
stadt ein fake brunnen einfach ja mach
das mal
ich schaue ich mal hier ein bisschen um
ob ich irgendwas finde ich es ist glaube
ich eine höhle outfit ist keine höhle
doch es ist eine höhle
ich habe eine höhle ja okay ich mich ich
bin hier du wirst abgeschaut von
scaletta abgeschlossen
hier sind so viele skelette lassen die
hüllen ok läuft am besten aus nicht dass
wir uns irgendwas leute verfolgen
ok jeden fall vierte mal ganz kurz das
eisen okay war ganz gut ich muss eben
dass es nicht das letzte keeper kommt
oder so lasst uns mal bitte hier eben
kurz
offen und sowas hinstellen und am besten
immer wenn eine ab dass der anderen die
anderen beiden richtungen schaut
bezüglich einer krippe hier ist wieder
ein großer eisenstadt
ich meine ich habe die övp ja das kann
sein ich habe immer angst dass sie von
der seite in kryta kommt oder irgendwas
alter bin richtig paranoid und habe ich
habe ich habe er zweifel zu helfen okay
du bist weiter runtergehen wie viele
erwarte ich noch hier ist nur ein
richtiger alten strom okay dann schmeißt
man besten schneiden die fackeln zu oder
werde hole ich so dass fixe einfach
genug kohle habe ich mir für bestens
text du dass wir am besten so viel
reisen
oh mein gott oh mein gott ich dachte das
[ __ ] alter und ich kann das eisen nicht
aufheben ich habe fackeln ich brauch mal
die höhle zu nicht dass sie tatsächlich
noch irgendwie kommen sollte
richtig sicher solange wir nicht viel
drin sind das ist mir alles lief
wirklich so
das gerät hat den boden fallen lassen
lässig lifestyle jetzt ihr weiter unter
das ja ich mal kurz die ganzen sachen
weg die ich nicht brauche erfahren
foto roland vitt mir eh nix bringen
mit mir eh nichts bringen jetzt nicht
jeder so ja aber so weit kommen wir
nicht verdammte scheiße hosen pegg
scotty schon mal weiter vorgehen du
geh'n wir erkunden ließ das im fackel
action millionen ist holz ist eine truhe
kein scherz
da ist eine truhe das da ist nun
goldbarren das aber wo kripo mein gott
warte ich hab noch ein bogen
oh mein gott er hier so ein holztor mit
natur da sind zwei goldbarren und 33
eisenbahnen und kohle aber dass kein
schild drauf ja die können wie save
nehmen da mache ich mir da keine sorgen
da kommt was rüber da kommt ja wie papas
auf das ist der krieg würde den
richtigen die einfach wenn er einfach
nicht hin aber lasst ihn nicht die kiste
in die luft okay die man die kiste war
ich hier noch reisen gesehen
hier ist auch noch überall eisen ich bin
ein bisschen weiter vorgegangen
okay wir müssen jetzt echt aufpassen
aber am besten wirklich das immer noch
einen abort weil ich hab keinen bock das
von hinten creeper kommt oder so einen
scheiß aber ich bin green wir brauchen
ein bisschen action ein bisschen high
life in unseren folgen wir sind so
richtiger draufgänger geworden wie ein
richtiger rebell nacht du heilige
scheiße alles okay dann nehme ich die
sachen jetzt aus der kiste raus warum
ist da überhaupt
ok ich kann diese warum euch blumen
du kannst die sachen nicht rausnehmen
doch ich habe die sachen wir haben
einfach ein dungeon gefunden
dahin ist noch eine kiste artikel ist
das denn alter
wir haben tatsächlich einfachen dungeon
gefunden dahin ich gehe zu der kiste
dahin ja ich war schon raus
ich muss erst mal was essen warte lass
mal kurz hier chillen in der ecke
holzkohle kommt mir bitte hier mithin
das ist in beide richtungen schauen
kannst du mich kurz ein bisschen
geschützt weil am platz ich eben die
öfen dass ich ein bisschen essen
zumindest mal braten kann ich baue dann
wird das holz ach ich hab doch soviel
gekochtes essen ich bin ja nur ein
dummkopf anstelle auf 77 mal
hammelfleisch okay ich mache uns erstmal
das noch ein bisschen eisen wie hielt
berät gerade 22 eisen ich mache mir aus
dem anderen alten war eben schon mal gut
dann kommen wir dem auto anreisen
eventuell schon wohl eingehen noch gar
keine rüstung
ja genau deswegen schon mal hinter dem
ofen
da müsste ein bisschen was dran sein
dann riesen damit wir dann ein bisschen
mehr eisen richtung hast du also bisher
läuft gut genauso habe ich mir quasi
vorgestellt ohne den keeper und das
andere ich hatte jetzt nicht gedacht
dass wir tatsächlich ist dungeons finden
direkt weiter jetzt ja oder aufgänge du
nicht lieber da warten wegen einer
rüstung ja gleich cook ja nur also hier
ist auf jeden fall ende
okay das ende ich weiß von anderen seite
geht es noch weiter dort finde ich
richtig
sowas macht spaß ja so was seine kunden
noch echt spaß passieren diese messen
ist auch noch reisen oben aber das
braucht man eben ab heisst schöne heiß
leute läuft bei uns alles
deutlich verflacht so haben wir eine
werkbank so wie ich weiß ja gar nicht
wichtig ganz zusammen reisen panzer noch
mehr eisen am besten mal alles was du
machen kannst auch noch eine aber keine
schuhe schon panzer habe ich schon am
besten ist man längst auch noch richtig
viel eisen save the ring gehen in dieser
folge ganz kann jetzt auch noch mehr
reisen
ok ja dann doch noch ab dann machen wir
das eben fertig ich denke wenn es jetzt
kann danach gedeutet wird doch keiner
mehr lacht ja das kann man endlich mal
so sagen ich mache noch im ofen eben
schnell damit er schneller geht richtig
krass am fahren wo hast du noch mehr
eisen gesehen also ich pause schon
weitergegangen draufgehen hier sind so
viele wege noch alter schwede
es ist richtig krass recht heftig so ich
mache mir mal eben noch eine leggins
sind ich bestimmt gleich gealtert ist
ein bisschen zu retten wollen das machen
wir gleich zusammen wir haben ja noch
sieben minuten aufnahmezeit das machen
wir gleich noch aber hier erst mal ich
bin jetzt gleich voll okay
das ist schon mal gut glaub ich weiß
nicht mehr wo ich zu dir kommen
ich bin froh wenn ich sehe den namen ich
sehe hier auch mal wieder am besten
zurück wieder wo ist tot
macht es hier unten na ja genau
und dann ich hoffe dass mein mann ist
ein alter noch mithalten so viel eisen
wir müssen halt auch echt aufpassen
wegen es gibt ja diese dürftigen spinnen
auch in diesen dungeons weiß überhaupt
gar nicht wie zum beispiel hose geht so
als ob dort stark hose und was ist mit
gesamtschule solchen nicht machen
doch du kannst ja alles machen für dich
weil also für mich braucht es jetzt
nichts machen weil ich schon fertig war
mit meinen sachen jetzt wegen schuh
weißt du wie man schlägt vor jahren
dicke ok dann lasst uns mal den schirm
mitnehmen
machen wir jetzt glaube ich meine reisen
spitzhacke da bin ich nur ein bisschen
fleisch beraten wenn wir sowieso hier
ich hab genug ich habe 27 fleisch ok
dann das spiel
das sollte reichen spitzhacke kann ich
dir meine erwarte ich geb dir die da
mache ich mir ebene neue wenn das
endlich in ordnung oder die online sind
weil ich hab' ich habe
also ich habe jetzt mal dann geht ihr
mann sich seine alte beck kannst du auch
ein bisschen holz geben
stark ihr katzen holz wird es so geil
der dungeon hat richtig druck
es ist echt haben wir haben jetzt
eigentlich erst mal genug eisen
die sache ist halt ich will jetzt nicht
die ganze zeit hier verweilen sondern
über warte lassen ein bisschen
weitergehen genau man mit recht weiter
in internationalen aber nie ob man die
sache ist wir haben noch drei minuten
aufnahmezeit das heißt lasst uns
zumindest schon mal eine kiste
hinstellen also ich bin dabei das wie
man unsere sachen oder wie wir das
machen wenn ich das hier ist eine
kompresse warst du ja aber dann kann er
sowieso nur die sachen die ihn im ofen
nehmen
ja aber das macht reisen wie lange kann
war dennoch sonst lass dir abbauen dann
nehmen wir die mittel auf noch ein
bisschen weiter hinten eine kuh ist ja
dann machen wir das so wir haben noch
bänke oder aufnahmezeit 33 minuten oder
so ich baue dann klappt einfach immer
die letzten sachen raus ok rausgenommen
und abgepackt niemand gibt immer die
öfen am besten oder warten im du dir mal
ich habe beide jetzt ich habe hier noch
zwei zugeworfen
okay ich habe halt aufpassen wegen dem
giftigen spinnen weil man nach leer zu
schmeißen oder das meerholz gegeben
moment lägen vor dir ja selber auch noch
ein paar gemacht gerade ist aus ist halt
wieder heißen ehrlich ja okay das
braucht man es eigentlich nicht mehr
man kann nie genug da komme ich zu dem
mit den diamanten sind jetzt eigentlich
erstmal besteller okay dass ich schaue
mich noch ein bisschen um hier dann bei
euch das eisen absolut bleibt schon mal
weiter jetzt
aber jetzt vielleicht brauchen wir ja so
vielleicht unser panzer und so
vielleicht fahren sich das so ab oder
wird so stark verbraucht wenn wir immer
kennen meist den ganzen leuten die alle
umbringen weil wir wollen gewinnen das
ist unser ziel dass nichts mehr
definitiv der partie definitiv live dann
geht es auch nicht lange wir könnten
hier hier gibt es noch runter denke ich
warte ich mittlerweile sind das für
klassisches eisen wir dann lass deinen
weg von vorhin gehen oder hier geht's
auch noch weiter hier geht es noch
weiter geht noch weiter wo ist hier die
admira genau in die andere richtung
geben welche einrichtung war okay ich
weiß zwar schon und dann am besten weg
ich reise mitnehmen
ich bin gerade okay ich habe jetzt noch
da unten ich einen job im spinnennetz
sagt noch so anderthalb minuten da hängt
ein zombie aber habe ich jetzt kommen
auf jeden fall schon ein bißchen
risikoreicher in kämpfe reingehen hier
hinten ist nichts mehr kommt zu dir nach
da hinten recht lobbyist auch nicht mehr
so als auch hier war ja noch was in der
ecke noch mal durch die wege einfach nur
so durch weil ich angst habe dass aus
den ecken irgend welche mmogs kommen
könnten
ich war schon wieder ein skelett comazo
mir war weil er ist audi riesige höhle
komme hierhin wo bist du jetzt eine
richtig richtige schluss da ist bestimmt
diamanten hatte ich hol dich ab ok ich
will deinen namen will ich im moment
jetzt müssen wir das sauna gazas einer
minute gekippt werden
hier ist die kasse schlucht
hier ist die hier ist die grenze wenn
wir jetzt in die andere richtung laufen
reisen dann nach unten muss doch
bestimmt auch mal hier diesen lägen
bisher nach vorne gucken ob ich da
irgendwo die am ein bisschen jetzt auf
jeden fall zusammen bleiben
ich will mich hat sie über diamanten
freunde diamanten werden schon hammer
weil wir darunter einfach mal hier
gibt's auch noch mal lang
ja wir können euch jetzt wasser springen
es war wieder so eine risiko aktion
alter und ich bin es unten in der höhle
leuchter alles aus ganz schnell wie
risikoreich wir auf einmal sagen wir
wurden uns ein
zu den profis hier ist nichts hier sind
keine die das regt mich gerade ein
bisschen auf ins aus schade man sind auf
welcher höhe sind wir wir sind auf höhe
30 okay wir können auch keine diaz sein
wo bist du so bist du in die andere
richtung gegangen wie scheiße kommen am
besten kannst du die hülle und da kommen
die schlucht er ich komme gern nahm das
sind und zusammen aussagen wie stehen
die letzten sekunden was das war eine
sehr produktive folge freuen
gefallen hat würden wir uns bei einem
eine bewertung freuen wir sehen uns
morgen wieder in warmbad 56 dass er das
tat 566 muss machen wieder